how uncomfortable are you
doing this doing this interview uh
majorly uncomfortable it's way outside
my comfort zone but
i'm doing it anyway
[Music]
aaron bush aka tripperhead ran his
twitter account anonymously for the past
two years
a bit of a hammer put it that way he's
become one of hong kong's biggest social
media influencers providing real-time
updates on the city's rapidly changing
coveted policies
so i'm a stay-at-home dad with two kids
who are growing up and don't really need
the dad bit of it anymore so i started
tracking this covet information from
january 2020 just for my own personal
information i had started a spreadsheet
i was tracking the numbers from china
just in case something was going to
happen so i started tweeting out that
information and then it started to
snowball he says he's not taking a day
off since
each day i'd watch the press conference
anyway so i thought oh well i might as
well put that information out
maybe one person out there doesn't know
that information and it'll help them out
we have intruded one
eight-year-old
girl a lot of the information that was
online was only in chinese so i was
started to translate the
local news stories into english for
people to read because they couldn't
read it
he breaks down press releases and
government data and answers questions
while injecting a little humor
i wake up i have a coffee and then it's
14 hours of doing the news reporting i
get to bed about 2am he does it
voluntarily but fans can buy him coffee
or send bitcoin
one of the big interesting things about
the
interest of that i'm receiving online is
it's almost it's 99.9 positive and i
mean everybody knows twitter is a
cesspool of horrid
one of the weird things with the trip
ahead twitter is everybody seems to be
in a community they want the news and
they ask a question i'll always answer
it the 47 year old australian native has
lived in hong kong for eight years
at no point did i expect me to be the
person responsible for the english
language hong kong covert news i'd never
tried to do that but the information at
the beginning and for a lot of the
outbreak to be honest hasn't been very
good in english there's only a handful
of local newspapers they
don't put stuff out immediately because
it's not their job aaron has met new
people through his platform it's
encouraged him to come out of a shell
i genuinely didn't do it for popularity
because it's a daily job so to do it
every single day for i think we're at
720 days in a row it does get tiresome
but if it does help out one person then
i'm glad that i do it i'm gonna keep
doing it until
it doesn't need to be done anymore
[Music]